Tao cơ quan cứu chợi động đất tiểu phương. Chị nó đơn mạnh nâng fẹi đổ sị ra và ngày 15 tại quận liệu
hàng thành của liêu châu thúc của tự tri dân tục truan còn tới Trung Quốc đã an rây dùng
lắt gió sế tầng nhiều khu vực gần cận. Rời chương sáng nhận goin nhất thái người thêm
mạnh, sau khi lực giận cục hộ tình thấy trong số các trình hợp mất tích băng đầu trên đó,
có băng người đều báo cá mất tích sau trại động đắn.
Ngay sau khi sự điều sị ra, chỉ quyết địa phương đã khi có thể chựu phó khần thấp. Điều đọc
đường công an cứ hoạ và sân quan tham gia tìm kiếm cứu nạn đồng thời sớt tả người dân tại khu vực bị an gồn.
Quảng hơn bình nguyên nồi đường dưới dưới đến hơi ăn quan, chúng khi có mấy ba công trình biểu 2 và sức đầu cú bộ.
Cơ quan có lý tham hoạch đậm đất Trung Quốc đã thiết hoạch mức ứng phó khẩn cấp cấp dà.
Đồng thời có cơ quan Trung hương cũng cử đàn công tác xuống hiện trường để phối hợp cứ hộ.
Chứ người phương tiếp tục kiểm tra ăn thần thẳng và khóc hộ quả, chúng có cảnh Wico dưu trình bán đực theo sỏi chất trảy.